my name is degree and I am the head of
technical operations at inspire tech
inspire Tech works with organizations to
revolutionize the digital workplace
today most organizations are trying to
find a balance between security and
accessibility inspire text file
collaboration platform easyshare enables
organizations to address such key issues
one of the challenges that organizations
face is how to allow internal users to
share files with external parties while
isolating the intranet from the Internet
to address this we deploy auditioning
what we refer to as hitch model in hitch
model we deploy three-tier architecture
in the intranet consisting of the web
application database servers and another
set in the DMZ with this only specific
files meant for external parties are
exposed to the Internet are the files
remains isolated within intranet we have
successfully deployed this solution to
many organizations in the on-premise
model with increasing demand for cloud
we were looking at for a cloud platform
that supports the same secure
architecture IBM's virtual private cloud
was the perfect match to our
requirements in Sparta is glad to be
able to deploy easy share on IBM's V PC
using the same network isolated
architecture which aligns with our focus
on security through IBM cloud we can now
easily leverage on other technologies
such as IBM cloud object storage to
scale our solution we look forward to
deploy more instances of EDA share in
the cloud for our customers
you